people that know you from social media
Instagram whatever they'll approach me
occasionally someone's like oh you ever
see garyvee I'm like yeah I kind of know
who that is he's he's an acquaintance is
that really who he is and I'm like dude
you have no idea like this is like he's
the tame version of himself you know I
don't know where you get the energy the
drive but I mean it's a blessing and and
you've done so much good with it man
it's just it's incredible
this is the garyvee audio experience
Vayner Nation this is uh a very special
friends giving episode of the garyvee
audio experience and for this
friendsgiving episode I haven't decided
if we're gonna air this on the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving on Thanksgiving
Black Friday the Saturday after but
somewhere here in a couple weeks we're
filming this on the 7th of November uh
we're gonna put this episode out and AJ
told me yesterday at the Jets game that
this is gonna be the first podcast he
listens to in years
so uh so that's all you need to know
about what you're about to get here so
I get to introduce my three best friends
growing up uh they they represent so
much to me for many that really follow
me we've talked about Edison New Jersey
so so so much and I talk about all that
the Only Rule I told these three best
friends of mine was I need you to come
and fly in because Robbie turnick to the
right of me he's still in the area but
Eric Godfrey has left and that name may
be familiar for some of you the hardest
core fans because Eric Godfrey is the
human being that made me a Jets fan and
probably for me personally the one that
excites me that's in the room the most
only because I've had the luxury of
jamming with Eric and Robbie a lot over
the last decade through jet games and
such even though Eric has moved to
Carolina is Andy Greco who also left the
area recently was living in Jersey but
now lives in Florida Andy Greco was the
only one of these three that was in my
actual grade Robbie was a great younger
Eric was a great older and moved into
Edison in my second grade year but left
in uh the middle of sixth or the
beginning of seventh grade I think
actually I'll let him tell but like so
for him to be here is really exciting
yesterday we all went to the Jets game
yes and they stunned the bills so I'm in
a good mood this may air after we lost
to the Patriots a second time so
hopefully that's not the case hopefully
we're still rolling but perfect Vibes
it's like 70 degrees outside which was
definitely not November weather when we
were growing up in Madison uh so I'm
really excited about this podcast they
are they've been tasked with trying to
remember stories we're gonna talk about
childhood we're just this is gonna be a
fun fun episode and hopefully really my
biggest uh takeaway from this is maybe
this inspires some of you given that
this is Thanksgiving week and some of
you may have some down time to just
reach out to a friend that you haven't
talked to in a while all three of them
because of the fact that we grew up
without technology meaning by the time
we were all in high school and college
and things of that nature there was no
internet or it was just starting uh cell
phones things that nature and so with
all all of these guys I had to reconnect
along the way starting with Robbie
reconnect we talked the most even like
by phone number I you know and things of
that nature but and then Eric later and
then Andy a couple years ago but so
that's the setup I'm gonna let them
introduce themselves and have an opening
statement
introduction who they are an opening
statement they're more than welcome to
share what they do professionally or an
interest but Andy will start with you
Andy Greco all right glad to be here
this is this is exciting it's a long
time coming I'm really excited to be a
part of this Gary thank you for inviting
me so of course my man um I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention who's not here with
us unfortunately our friend Marissa who
was supposed to be part of this years
ago when we first talked about it yes
but unfortunately she recently passed
away so uh you know we want to dedicate
this to her as well 100
um but uh yeah and her family she has
she has an amazing family I stayed in
touch with her over the years sorry to
interrupt Andy but she has an amazing
son who just graduated high school
um and an amazing daughter who is
amazing at she's great at soccer she's
she's kicking ass at soccer from what I
understand and one of the nicest guys
I've ever met she you know had the
privilege of burying our friend Marissa
so I just want to say that Dave Striker
he's a great guy
awesome so you know it's a little sad
when you think who's not with us but at
the same time super excited to be with
Robbie and Eric and you Gary I mean this
is like you know a dream you know to be
here with you and to see where you've
come and considering where you came from
who knows better than the three of us at
this table of course I mean uh it's just
it's just nothing short of spectacular
what you've accomplished man and I'm so
proud of you so thank you brother I'm
really glad to be here glad you're here
yeah I'm so I'm I'm that guy
and Sasha will say thanks for ruining
our live and there's something along
those lines every time I see him which
is rare
um yeah again I I tell my people all the
time how proud I am you man like like
and I'll get into it more later when
we're talking about it but like
uh everything Gary always says is true
about where he came from like my mom
before she passed away she would tell me
stories about how Gary would come over
hungry you know what I mean and he would
give him snacks and stuff like that and
like that was like one of her stories
that she always remembered about you
um but yeah super happy to be here so
proud of you man that's because I didn't
eat as a kid we're all very skinny all
of us I just like not me
you were big yeah yeah you were probably
the Eater of the bunch yeah we all
played a lot yes like Wisconsin I would
I would need snacks because we just
literally played sports for four and a
half hours yeah every day and Bishop R's
uh there's a couple people here that
work that work at Vayner that went to
Bishop R that's interesting and I always
tell you probably way after us yeah yeah
they're all youngsters but anyway Robbie
turnick uh Rob turnick uh big green Rob
for those that know me on Twitter a lot
of you guys already know who I am I met
a lot of you at V con I'm happy to be
part of the V friends family
um Happy to be part of Gary's Life
this man changed my life for the better
I'm gonna cry he got me out of so many
jams that like
I can't even tell you I appreciate this
guy more than anything
and uh I knew I was gonna get choked up
I haven't had a chance to tell him like
this like how much he means to me and
how much he affected my life in a
positive way I was going downhill in a
bad way
and right around that time his wouldn't
be friends came out and saved my life
it really did
so I want to thank you for that I love
you man love you too
all right let's go to the before we
really cried out here let's go yeah
let's go to the origin let's this should
be a lot of fun because I think what
could be really fun about this is like
anybody who's listening was like a
friend group or reconnected with friend
group I think a lot of our origin
stories you don't fully remember it the
same way because it's [ __ ] hundred
years ago right I met Eric and Robbie
literally within the first couple of
weeks of living in Edison New Jersey I
moved in August there was a there was a
huge fall it's really I'm gonna paint
this picture for you there was this huge
Farm now remember this is 1982 Edison is
now converting like much of New Jersey
from like Farmland people don't really
know Jersey like that like right there
was a farmer we all know Farmers like
literally a actual Farmer Joe who sold
his farm to a developer and a developer
built these townhouses which go ahead I
was just gonna say because I lived there
in my whole life and I distinctly
remember before meeting Gary I remember
the fence in my backyard
this is how profound this says these two
guys lived
three houses away right like yeah real
right exactly three houses away on
Tingley Lane which by the way is a name
of a company here now at vaynerx tingly
Lane trading which yeah we just
announced it so I have a new company
called tingly Lane training uh it's a
barter Media Company it's literally
called tingly Lane trading that's
awesome
um and they live three three houses
apart Robbie's house was right on close
to the road Eric's house was way deeper
down so it's really interesting they
weren't they were on the same road but
they were kind of like one was on the
front row back and then it was wrapped
around this huge Farm which I don't know
they both knew because they remember it
in their early because they were like
seven and six when I met them so like
they were super little but they remember
it that farm sells and they build this
thing called Dogwood Meadows yeah and so
Dogwood Meadows is this townhouse that
opens in 1982 and one of the first six
or seven people to move in is Sasha and
Tamara vaynerchuk and and my sister's
best friend growing up Denise Laurie she
lived in one of those houses well and
was one of the first residents and her
house backed into Eric's house and we
all literally lived within uh I mean me
and Robbie's house and my house touched
with this hill so we were I don't know
somebody help me here I'm not good with
feet
probably about maybe 100 feet like yeah
actually yeah and then Eric was 300 feet
to the left instead of the back and so I
I met Robbie uh Robbie's version I
remember the story yeah our version's
the same I go outside
first I recognize there's a kid outside
I've seen a kid I saw a kid in my back
he looks my age that's all I know so the
next day I see him the first day the
second day I go outside you have to
remember this is a development in
development like the houses are still
being built around here and so there's
mud and woods and like there's all sorts
of [ __ ] going on and there's like a
t-shirt in the mud that is like a
t-shirt it's in the mud
I pull it out and
go to the house that I saw the kid and
ask them if it's their t-shirt
t-shirt go ahead the way I remember it
was just you know again to date myself
82 that's about right I was five years
old it was a summer before I went to
kindergarten right and I was it was a
Saturday morning I was sitting in the
den playing in television and again it
wasn't as hot out it was a nice day so
the back door is open and all of a
sudden I see I got something out of the
corner where I move I look over I turn
to my right and I see Gary with his
hands up against the glass peeking in my
window with Liz standing behind him
who didn't speak a lick of English
either yeah she didn't no and uh yeah
that was
Dover
and that so I got a little something Liz
was still at home
I was in the mix-ish and yes that's
exactly right Rob I was looking through
the like you know and like is this your
t-shirt that got us to talk that started
the process
I think it took me less than five
minutes to get ready to go out and play
with him at that point like almost that
fast and then how I remember it and Eric
actually actually before I lead the
witness I have no idea if you can
remember do you know when we first met I
I have a I have a memory that might be
right
what's yours
what I remember is football and
literally the story that you always tell
and like you've been telling it for
freaking years like that's my first
memory and you know listen over the
years I've
had some drinks you know what I mean so
my memory may not be what it what it
should be but I remember playing
football
and you coming yep and asking you like
you know like your English was not good
yep and I remember asking you like
because I had just become a Jet fan yeah
my just I was not born into the Jets
right um I should actually lead with
this actually okay um so my mother my
father is is honestly a straight hippie
like he doesn't care about sports at all
yep
um my mother is a die-hard yaggy fan
like I remember we lost her several
years ago but a huge huge Yankee fan
dude it wasn't super into the NFL
that's why I'm a Yankee fan you also
made me a Yankee fan yeah I like and
like your mom made you a Yankee fan so
I'm literally a Yankee fan because
you're a mom yeah
um so the long story short with the Jets
like my dad even though he didn't give a
[ __ ] at all he would still watch with me
because he was he's a great father yep
and so we're watching and this is 81 81
they're terrible like really bad yep so
I turned to my dad and I'm like my
favorite color is green so I already
have that yep and I turned my dad and my
dad this team is terrible and I remember
him saying to me like it's fun to roof
in the underdog sometimes and like from
that between being green and being five
or five years old and just not knowing
anything I was a Jet fan from that
moment and then the first season we had
together was 82 and they went to the AFC
Championship yes and that was like we
cried oh like we cried we hated AJ Dewey
the most yeah the Dolphins when my
parents told me my brother was named AJ
I was devastated
that never actually are you kidding me
that was like the [ __ ] can worst thing
that I could we AJ Dewey was the single
human I hated the most on Earth
until my brother was named it all right
so I remember Robbie and I just become
friends Robbie had an iconic at least
for the four of us an iconic jungle gym
this is an iconic jungle yes it was and
it wasn't like like it's not like for
all the youngsters it's not like the
[ __ ] you see now that like it was like
Robbie helped me it was it was just like
the framework made out of wood with like
like large wooden dowels like like bars
that you hang on like the kind you would
hang clothes on make that my dad built
it yeah they said well they sold them as
kits back then that's what it was it was
there was no slide there was no swings
there was nothing do you remember the
casino yeah yeah I was yeah I was gonna
go okay save that same yeah anyway
Robbie has this jungle gym it's super
cool I'm scared shitless of climbing it
my friend Robbie here to the right is an
iconic cliche 80s kid this [ __ ] kid
didn't see a tree he didn't want to
climb he was like
you were amazing anyway so Robbie and I
are friends this is still summer this is
still August and I'm telling you we
moved in
August so it's August we're all about to
go to school Robbie to kindergarten meet
a first grade Eric to second grade Eric
even though he lived literally 200 feet
from me did not go to the same grammar
school as us because the grammar school
we were all gonna go to burnt down right
Oak Tree Road right Oak Tree Road I
don't remember and Martin Luther King
Martin Luther King was nice right Martin
Luther King was new and was being built
but we would have done probably another
they like I don't know exactly how it
broke down but me and Robbie went to
Martin Luther King and you went to what
Eric uh
so which was really sucked by the way
between Eric going to a different
grammar school and always going to sleep
away camp I will tell you right now
I'm so grateful from 82 to 89 I got
every minute with Robbie like we hung
out every minute the great
disappointment for me was that I didn't
get as much time with Eric as I wanted
because he went to a different grammar
school and he went to sleep away and I
was always pissed when he would go away
for the summer and then obviously not
enough time with Andy we'll get to his
Baltimore Colts leaving in the night
part of our friendship in a minute so
but Eric here's how I remember it we
were in I so me and Robbie just met we
played maybe two times three times seven
days 12 days not a lot couldn't bid a
lot and then he said my other friends
are coming over I actually want to talk
about you two if you remember when you
guys met or for how long but you but
Eric and Ellen his sister Ellen Eric and
Ellen came over and they were playing on
the jungle gym with me and Robbie and
that's the first time we actually met
but it was like quick it was like late
in the afternoon we kind of all hung
like you know for 10 15 20 minutes and
then this then the Nerf ball football
stuff happened later but did you you
guys had known each other or not yet
um no we we had met yeah prior
um because just because we were so close
and that and our parents even though
they weren't super tight but they were
friendly well back I mean don't forget
this was neighborhoods in the 80s yeah
everybody knew everybody knew each other
and did you know Lindsay across the
street from you
yes Lindsay's in that iconic picture of
you me and her when we were like going
to kindergarten in first grade for the
first time yeah there was a girl across
the street on tingly Lane who lived in a
house she left literally that that year
I moved to Seattle right Oregon thank
you that was in touch with her mom for a
long time and I know she went into the
military I don't know much else about
that yeah Lins if you hear this you're
out there yeah if you're out there Gary
yeah Robbie still lives if I'm still in
the same house you could find me um
did you know Lindsay across because
Ellen and Lindsey were friends that's
what I'm saying yes I I wasn't like she
and I were friends personally play with
nobody yet not really right because Rob
was two years young yeah because I'm so
young like those licensing guys like
until I was like really like you went to
that school you're right right so that
that's when I met all those other dudes
like Benji sabrin so you kind of met
when you met me you were just starting
me down right pretty much like it was
all around each other but like
and then there was a new kid and there
was it didn't really think anyway
Andy yeah yeah get in here you come two
years later I was late to the party so I
joined I think 980 85 85-ish so we're
talking like third grade to like
beginning of seventh grade it was third
grade right yeah I knew you weren't in
my second grade picture yeah it was
third grade and uh did you come in when
did you come in there's some you know
you came a little bit in I think it was
beginning of the school year I want to
say like September October yeah it
wasn't even summer no it wasn't it's
because it was mid-school years I
remember my first day of school I had to
like walk in in the classroom not
knowing anyone and it was just like I
didn't even know you then
um I think the first time we met and you
moved into Dogwood Meadows moved into
Dogwood Meadows like a block and a half
for me from you guys from you know you
and Robbie basically were next door
neighbors and Eric was across the yard I
was a little bit farther away a block
and a half away
um and when I moved in I knew no one I
remember the first the first memory I
have meeting you and I think Eric was
there too you're at the courts playing
basketball and I just made a lot of
things I just yeah yeah we did yeah yeah
yeah I got some stories dust how much
time what time is it
great so we have to 115 right because
there's a buffer all right we're gonna
get into it go ahead yeah so I mean
come to the courts now to paint a
picture I lived in a cul-de-sac right
Robbie's right behind me because he
wasn't part of the development he was on
the street yes Eric if you if if you
think about what a house looks like in a
cul-de-sac I'm looking at the basketball
Robbie's in the back I'm looking at the
basketball courts Eric's to the left
Andy's to the right and there's they
just built these basketball courts and
tennis courts this is fancy [ __ ] for all
of us oh my God totally go ahead yeah so
yeah that's a good point you bring that
up I mean we didn't live in a luxurious
development there were Town Homes we had
a basketball court a tennis court and
like a little you know Green area to
play but we we maximized it I mean we
used it non-stop so I I roll up on my
bike it's like summer of or fall of
1985. you knew to Gary take your bike
and try I was just exploring I was just
exploring I was like I heard the report
you were in Bloomfield I grew up in born
and raised in Bloomfield until I was
since third grade then we moved to
Edison you were used to what we were
used to which is go outside find kids
play that's it I'm just painting this
picture because I know a lot of people
are 25 and I have no idea what the [ __ ]
we're talking about yeah no it's just
random there was no this was interacting
there was no play dates there was no
Facebook meetup groups it was none of
that we just go find friends they said
go outside we have food here when you
come back exactly exactly seriously be
home for dinner and have fun and you
have all that land and [ __ ] to do and
you know what I mean oh my God we're
doing great you know both of our fathers
are working there
I left like four in the morning yeah go
ahead so I remember just rolling up to
the courts you guys were playing
basketball Gary was like fully focused
on the basketball game it was him Eric I
think it was like a two on two Eric and
Gary versus two random kids I have no
clue who they were but but Gary was like
laser focused he was like all about
winning and uh I just remember watching
for a few minutes and at some point I
know if somebody got hurt but you looked
over Gary and you saw me on my bike and
you're like hey you want to play and I'm
like yeah why not you know I'm not a
great basketball player but I'll give it
a
shot
you know I came I came onto court and uh
you know I held my own and you know I
earned some respect from day one with
you guys and after that I think it was
just like hey where do you live we got
stuck to talk I'm like oh I'm right down
the street I just moved in and uh we
didn't exchange numbers or anything I
just said I'll see you tomorrow you know
I came out the next day and then you
know I think the next day we did like a
wiffle ball game at Eric's house in his
yard and uh and then I got to meet
barracks and then maybe like a week
later you introduced me to Robbie and it
was like
I remember being pumped because my two
best friends were not in my class right
Robbie was one year younger in my school
Marissa was in my case yeah and Marissa
lived down the street in tingly Lane and
like you would have been in Allen's
class but I would have been Ellen but
yeah that's right and so I remember you
being in my class yes and that was the
coolest like oh my God my friend an
actual friend is actually in my class
and that was the best yeah it was great
I mean we we had such a great childhood
I mean all we did was play sports you
know literally it was just it literally
it was that's all we did basketball
tennis yeah like video games no and
lemonade cold set golf wall ball all the
games you made up I made up so much you
made it golf Robbie I love your face
right now I made up this crazy ass game
there was a good job there was a gutter
there was a gutter water gutter at it's
in the cul-de-sac right on the curb it
was right on the curb in front of my
house we would go to the end of the
cul-de-sac which was closer feet away
and we we would roll the tennis ball
you'd try to get a hole in one and then
you remember and no matter where it
landed you had to use yourself
what I remember in that cul-de-sac was
Spud he played [ __ ] Spud forgot about
Spud right that was like categories and
you'd throw it down that cul-de-sac was
Central yes
100 you had that that open space between
your house and the neighbors it was just
like a little Courtyard shout out to
John and Linda they were my neighbors
yeah they shared they shared backyard
and they completely gave it to me yeah
and us oh yeah right
and destroy your flowers yeah
if you're the grand kids of John and
Linda who lived in Edison in 1982 on
Teaberry drive like I need to hear from
you because like they were the sweetest
they were retired he would always want
to deliver great he always had the bread
delivery truck unbelievable yeah
unbelievable so that was that's how we
met that's how we met and then from
there it was just you know we were in
school together and we became super
tight and I just remember like one of my
first memories of you is you are always
looking for ways to make money right
this is no here we go no
need started that hustle probably in
like 1983. yeah so you you were always
you know tagging me along with you on
these ideas you had where there was a
lemonade stand or one of my favorites
was uh the car wash so so here's here's
a good story yeah so it's Saturday
morning 1986 it's about seven in the
morning I think I spoke to you the night
before and you're like you're like
you're like tomorrow we're gonna do
something to make money I'm not sure
what it is yet but we're gonna figure it
out so I was thinking you know he might
roll up around 10 o'clock no 7 A.M my
doorbell rings it's this guy standing at
the door with standing at my front door
with with a garden hose over one
shoulder he's got a bucket with a sponge
and a bottle of his mother's dish
detergent the other that's exactly right
and he's like come on dude we're gonna
we're gonna go make some money I'm like
we're gonna miss the boat everyone's
Gonna Leave they've got plans for
Saturday we got to get out there we
gotta I'm like all right let me let me
get out of my pajamas and go go wash
cars with you Gary so sure enough I get
dressed throw on some shorts we go
outside we go door to door ringing the
doorbell hey can we wash your car it's
five bucks we'll do a great job if
you're not happy get your money back
like Gary had the whole pitch that was
just I was just the idiot carrying the
hose we used their water and we we ran
out of soap and at some point somebody
just gave us some soap but we were I
mean he just it was all about just
making something from nothing I mean it
was 100 you know it was there was
nothing you wouldn't try it was just you
know from day one I met you that you
were just driven dude it's just it's
just how you were how you were wired 100
and it you know to see where you've come
in life
it's it's surprising because I never
expect you to get to this level but
again it's not you know because you were
always wired to be that guy you were
just always thinking of the next thing
the next thing and I mean it just played
out really well for you man it's it's
it's a it's it's a great thing to be a
part of and I mean even though you know
it was only three or four short years
where I lived with you guys in Edison I
mean I have such fond memories of those
years even to this day I mean people oh
God it's cool people that people that
know you from social media Instagram
whatever they'll approach me
occasionally someone's like oh you ever
see garyvee and I'm like yeah I kind of
know who that is he's he's an
acquaintance and they're like yeah you
know he's just uh uh you know I don't
know is he real is he really like is is
that really who he is and I'm like dude
you have no idea like this is like he's
the tame version of himself that's funny
because I use the exact phrase you have
no idea he's just he's just you know I
don't know where you get the energy the
drive but I mean it's a blessing and and
you've done so much good with it man
it's just it's incredible I gotta bring
up stories we'll get to it I want to
keep going around but we got to talk
about your basement in 1986 because when
Mike Tyson's Punch-Out came out oh yeah
I lived in Andy that's the time I spent
the most time in your house because
because Hanukkah was late that year
that's right and so Andy had Mike
Tyson's punch out we started really
hanging in that basement yeah for sure
we had uh yeah I got the Nintendo
Entertainment System that had to be
Christmas of 86. that's exactly right
and uh I got three games I got Mario
which came with the console I got uh
Tyson's punch out and I got the
legendary The Legend of Zelda I know
that and we were just like Non-Stop and
I remember like you had to wait did you
ever get Mike Tyson's punch out that
year or did you have to wait
we shared a lot the three of us I never
had it I never had it I played it at
your house right I had excitements
Robbie's room
playing excitebike listening to Twisted
Sisters
I just found a rundium a Yom TV reps
card in my basement of bismarckee
[Music]
yeah Eric what do you remember about
those earliest days different School
sleep away camp like what's up yeah I
mean definitely when you first first we
were like Inseparable and separate like
literally like every day and like that
that that's what I lived for that's like
it's all I really wanted to do was play
sports like yeah even when I did get
into video games with you guys but not
as much like you got cooler than we did
like you got into girls way before yeah
we were like we like had crushes but you
were like trying to really do it right
like yeah like you were about that life
I remember in like fifth grade the girls
were fighting over you yeah I thought it
was very well I was Rocky you guys saw
Xander yesterday that that face and the
Charisma like I was very strong in
fourth and fifth grade but no Eric you
yeah you by the time we got into video
games in 86 I was 11 you were 12. you
were 12 was 19. Yeah well yeah you were
very focused in here yeah you were like
it was Sports and girls yeah we're like
it was Sports though yeah in the
beginning yeah I mean I thought I could
be good like I mean I was you were tall
I was gonna say you were like six foot
when he was 12. 100 now you're six one
right you were really tall right like
like I remember like
yeah always tall
and taller than like taller than me now
I'm six foot three while we're early in
the podcast especially if like relatives
or friends of these people we're looking
we're definitely looking for Bobby Duffy
who also lived on tingly Lane I think
his family still lives there is that
right that's one of the houses that has
not been torn down so I'm pretty sure
his family still lives there he was in
the mix when I want to stick on 82 83 80
45 before we get to like 86 87 88
83.84 Not only was it us Andy was just
about to come and then came but Bobby
Duffy was in the mix with us Sports he
played football we played a lot of
football yeah we were we played wiffle
ball we played aluminum bat tennis ball
in the cul-de-sac home run that's how I
chipped my tooth already yeah remember I
hit my face with the back yeah tooth
came out and then you remember the
second time I chipped my tooth when I
bit the car and made pretend I was
George Animal steel yes all right we'll
talk about that later
um uh but we played a lot of football
and you need more you know me and you
played a lot of one-on-one Wiffle ball
automatic yeah so that didn't take a lot
of people football did so we had Bobby
Duffy and then Andrew and Gregory the
twins
Robbie you knew their last names
there we go that's it all right so weird
everybody's listening we're looking for
Andy uh and Gregory bastito who lived in
Edison as the twins talk about those
guys were monsters
they were in fifth grade when I was in
second I remember that vividly because
that's when I think they moved they were
three years older me and looked like my
father like like I look like their child
and they were core they were outside all
the time too they played those two in
Bobby Duffy and us three then Andy came
that would and then Michael bronfman
came in who also lived on tingly Lane
Michael Brown when we're looking for you
to cross the street from you yeah he
came in like around the time you came in
yeah
hey gang you're probably hearing that my
audio is different now and as much as
I'd like to blame it on Dustin because
it's always fun and it's like an inside
joke I just did another podcast where I
hit the wire again and this time I
actually like knew what was happening
because Dustin just told me I [ __ ] up
in this podcast so luckily it sounds to
me like fine and you'll be able to hear
me but obviously you're about to sense a
change in audio I just want to jump in
and say sorry and I love you and
remember to pair hi hi fruit forward
Reds with your Thanksgiving dinners if
you haven't bought your wine yet
that was Marissa may she rest in peace
that was the crew yeah yeah and even
like stragglers because we we I mean
listeners well that's what I was gonna
just get to we had the wars between
Dogwood Meadows and the Oaks the other
condos that are literally across the
street from the others three times every
summer second
third and the big one was sixth grade I
reached out okay I reached out to him on
Facebook but he didn't answer me oh man
I like I actually you know I've talked
to Brian Shannon Dixon I talked to Dixon
those are kids we went to school with I
didn't live in our neighborhood and
nobody like you like okay like Brian
said at a sleepover birthday party that
was iconic so and then Tyler bunting who
passed right many many years ago 20
years ago it's funny two of my core
friends that were outside of you that
were school friends both passed Rich
Regan when you were still in high school
yep my senior year I think I think so
was my the was my Macho Man Randy Savage
right him and Abel Franco April Franco I
connected with too was on a video with
me yeah Abel Franco and Richard and me
were the Macho Man Randy Savage guys
my class yeah and then and then and
Tyler bunting passed and what I remember
about Tyler my third grade birthday
party was at my house and everybody came
over and we played football on the grass
in between the cul-de-sac and the
basketball court and like that was on
the time that was the place I bought
ODed first when I jumped on his back and
just pounded his back actually the air
came out of his little body
no actually you know what big shout out
to Odette Weinstock we really really
fought second third sixth grade like
really had a rivalry I bet Andy probably
has some memories because he was in that
class yeah but right before I moved
because I moved at the end of seventh
grade we were actually very friendly in
seventh grade we played tennis on Oak
Tree Road
we had a nice tennis match that was like
our a men's day like instead whatever it
is yeah I didn't know that either
um go ahead yeah I mean ODed was he was
he was in our grade and I just remember
he was always a rivalry
yeah it started like a verbal War back
and forth if you know who could roast
him the worst and then it would open the
violence it was crazy because we used to
all like the big fights were always at
this kid marcos's house in middle school
yeah in Middle School like I don't know
what it was but that was a thing
yes yes
yeah we went to John Adams Middle School
all of us I remember how pumped I was
that me and Eric were gonna be in the
same school which was the best you left
before I got there
I didn't we were never in middle school
together of course we were when I was in
seventh grade you were in sixth
yeah
we have one year okay uh uh remember me
and Marissa and Andy and do you remember
when me you and Marissa in sixth grade
when Rodney was still in fifth we used
to walk to school and me you and Marissa
you remember the story you know I know
where you're going me and Marissa like
we always would make like bombs like
[ __ ] yeah I did and medium loved it and
me you and Marissa were doing something
in Robbie's yard
jump in a second but me and we would the
three of us that would be our meeting
point and we would walk to school we
were doing something at a cop rolled up
on us huh tell us Robbie all right well
yeah you know fireworks coming Jersey
we're expecting we're uh illegal and um
my dad happened to have some bottle
rockets at the time yes I stole them out
of the garage and I hit him up in the
bushes which just happened to be where
Gary and Andy and Marissa met to walk to
school together and they found him and
the cops rolled by and saw them in their
land yes
sure yeah likely story but we just fine
you did because I put them there 100 I
remember that
oh [ __ ] I think my mom came out I don't
know what else what else look Andy I see
you got to listen oh yeah I got my list
rattle off your list let me okay what's
up guys got the car wash story and I had
Brian Chen you brought him off yes epic
birthday party that was like winning the
lottery
just so everybody knows Brian Chen's
sleepover birthday party which I went to
like three or four years and Addison and
he was like right on the border with
Clark I don't think you guys what you
didn't you knew him later this was
grammar school right I didn't and you
were on Yeah by people it was Tyler
bunting Max Thomas Max Thomas holy [ __ ]
yeah Max Thomas and Tyler were always
there because that was his core I and
him and I were really close I was there
remember Michael Wong course smartest
kids Michael bong is the only kid in our
third grade who voted for Michael
Dukakis instead of Ronald Reagan you
know I saw this house we brought the
story up he's like that's why Dustin
knows we did a class poll in 84 and
everybody voted for Ronald Reagan except
for Michael Wong and I'll think about
this this is now 30 [ __ ] 40 years
later and I still remember yeah
so smart
go ahead so all right so I got that so
what about by the way Brian just saw
everybody Brian said sleepover party
was the equivalent of going to Coachella
right the Super Bowl
Ibiza and Vegas for a month and winning
this 1.9 billion dollar power lot and
that's how big of a [ __ ] deal this
party was yeah I mean yeah it was by the
way it was just a sleepover room playing
video games it's just like the 80s he
sold it that's what he was like the
week's leading up to that party it's
like oh we're gonna have this game Brian
Chen's what sleepover was the first time
I heard Guns and Roses wow
[Music]
Jennifer the ugly Jennifer the ugly
the big meal I think I sent you the
lyrics
I don't think people understand like
when people I love when sometimes people
like scary even like hip hop I'm like if
he's back to if they knew oh yes I
thought we thought we were going to be
professional we thought we were the Fat
Boys we really want to one day we'll be
the fat boy we see voices
we didn't wear shoelace like it was
everything yes we were born into that
era it was just you know that was fifth
grade on the bus and we come home Robbie
was on our bus he was in fourth and we
were in the back of the bus we ran that
bus yeah and we [ __ ] let's represent
you ran it up at school yeah and so
we'll have to get do you remember that
election yes
yeah Gary's uh fifth grade was class
president
um yeah that was the time for school
went kindergarten to fifth grade fifth
grade is the presidential election now
it's fifth grade yeah and um
just give you an idea timeline the vice
president with this kid Scott Robinson
who I helped him might be posting for I
mean his phone for Scott Robinson for
Miami Vice President that's the time
framework
Gary's passed out dumb dumb lollipops
and Captain Morgan gold plastic coins to
get people's votes I would like to see
if he did in school today pass out
Captain Morgan does not get lost you're
a fifth grader takes from promotional by
the way anytime you played football in
the backyard you gave me a Captain
Morgan hat and I had to be the Pirates
you were and then you ended up being on
the pilots
and you know what I made the All-Star
Game and you get Gary and Eric actually
came out today
I remember like [ __ ] yesterday
I remember I I do you know how vividly
the reason I just brought up you were on
the Pirates I remember that bigly that
we came and supported I remember vividly
being stunned you were good
I know you kept getting better and
better and better with your hand eye and
then I because of that I stopped playing
what about wrestling yeah
wrestling in my basement we did
WrestleMania with the twins I think we
did like a Survivor Series
in fifth grade are twice the size that I
am now
it's like they're like six two three
hundred like Monsters 12. and and Gary
was always like they were tag teaming
him it was always Gary versus the twin
and somehow he held his own I mean you
were getting suplexed and pile driven
you would just it was all mental I just
refused
every single time I was in a death match
against Marissa like even ropes and
jeans swinging and yeah you remember
what I really remember is I it would I
would head butt people because my head I
was just convinced that I couldn't hurt
my head and most people just didn't like
getting hit in the head with the head
remember I don't I seriously think I
forgot all of these stories because you
have a matter of head butts
so Gary was a much better tennis player
than me it was because Eric it was
because Eric was good yeah and I wanted
to beat him and so I would when he would
go to sleep away I would play tennis
against my wall where we played wall
balls for [ __ ] seven hours a day
that's right one-on-one tennis by myself
pretty good I got a good opinion yeah
and that's a perfect segue where I'm
going with this so we we you and I I was
the arbor player when I first played we
had the wooden rackets
and you you actually worked with me if
you wanted somebody that was decent that
could you know challenge you so if
everyone was missing Eric because he
started going to sleep everywhere
you got to fill in so so sure enough I I
took a liking to it yeah I started
practicing on my own and uh you know you
would destroy me it would be like six
one and like usually by the way I just
wanted to know my feelings are coming
back yeah
it feels Michael so it's still a little
blurry blurry think when I know where to
go ahead so he you know he just you know
we didn't play often when we when we did
play like you were super annoying so I
decided I'm gonna practice and then one
day you're like hey you want to play
some tennis I'm like yeah sure why not
let's try it out we'll probably kick my
ass but let's give it a try so we played
and the first set I think you beat me
like six four and you were like confused
you usually just nominated I would be
like six one or six girl and the one
game be like a mercy one just so I would
quit yeah exactly
good job Andy so so this first set like
you were trying and I was trying it was
six four yes so you're like all right
well you know you got better you know
yeah a little bit a little bit the
second set I somehow beat it yeah like
six four yeah I'm starting to remember I
think we're like holy [ __ ] like you're
just like something was just in your
head just not Computing and you're like
we got to play this third set this is it
this is it and I ended up winning the
third set yes and you were just lost my
holy [ __ ] you just took direct you're
like I gotta go in the house this is
crazy it just blew your mind
a week later I think you spent the next
week practicing [ __ ] practice Yeah
it's the wall and then you beat me like
six one six two you're like all right
all this right over the world I was so
confused I remember
this is what I wanted from this podcast
but you know it was it was I mean at the
time it was intimidating to play in
sports because you wanted to win you had
to win but it pushed us all to be better
like the rush Point like he wasn't a
great player and then all of a sudden
push them and you know you always raise
the bar and you continue to do that look
at in your personal life in your
professional life I mean you raise
people up that's why you know it's funny
when I wrote my last book 12 and a half
comp competition being competitive was
in it and I took it out because I
actually want to write a book about just
competition and how important it
actually is and we shouldn't demonize it
we shouldn't give me Place trophies and
it's okay to cry when you lose
absolutely think about it guys how much
did I cry when I lost from 19. 1980 you
hated to lose yeah you did hate to lose
but I wasn't afraid to cry either I
cried at all the time right and then he
would keep playing until he beat your
ass like yeah the game wasn't over until
he won the man was gone okay we're good
now we can move on I wish friend you and
I were very competitive yeah yeah Sam's
still yeah to this day in different ways
of selling myself yeah it was so that
was such a fun era all right what about
SummerSlam
sleepover now my immigrant mom Tamara
finally lets me have one and it's
SummerSlam first one first one
pay-per-view which was unheard of my mom
letting me buy pay-per-view you have to
understand that's like buying a
Rolls-Royce by spending 18 or whatever
it was was like a billion
for all of us I will never forget this
sleepover to this day I die yeah that
was amazing especially because Elizabeth
took yes they lovely Elizabeth Randy the
Macho Man the Savages manager took over
took off a piece of clothes and had like
a mini skirt on and literally I turned
to Andy and I was like I think I Think
We're Men now
I remember
Eric's like let me explain to you
shine it is
yeah I would sit there playing with Hulk
Hogan songs you're like you want to play
with the rubber wrestle here we go that
was right you should bring the wrinkles
we played that you didn't choose to chew
the feet and hands off of them yeah I
used to put everything in my mouth
not everything not everything all right
whatever what else do you remember give
us some more like Vivid memories Story
Time what do you remember when people
like give us a story
a lot of my [ __ ] to be honest with you
is I don't know if this is cool but it
comes later go ahead go ahead um
um
so
uh about six years ago we lost my mother
unfortunately uh my sister and I
I just have a couple things my sister
and I are drinking which we like to do
um my entire family went to because this
is the first year without my mother we
all went to Texas
and I believe this is when the story
came out but Ella and I had drinks and
somehow it came up that Ellen and Gary
were each other's first kiss now at this
point I'm like four I know at this point
I'm like I'm like 42 and I'm like
obviously I don't give a [ __ ] but I was
just like how did no one tell me like
this me and Ellen made it back yeah I'm
very disappointed that Ellen broke it
not the whole world knows yeah
um and then another one I remember
Ellen's birthday party at a movie
theater oh totally and my mom made me
give her a rose it was like this big
thing yeah I don't know is it back to
the future quite possible I think it was
that was it that was it I'm pretty sure
um so I thought that was a pretty funny
and funny tidbit but yes she ruined the
pack so
um Ellen was also six foot one
um
excellent excellent women's basketball
player yeah yeah very very I remember
when her and Marissa were on the team
together I was like so pumped because
they were good friends but went to
different schools as well because that
was Marissa and our like we said with
Alan went to a different school and we
all converged in Middle School each
other
yeah
I remember those games go ahead
um so
piggyback you know just something a
little bit different so and you probably
know this already but like the day that
Gary's parents decided to move was like
and we were older by this point it was
like I was devastated
so it was we just lost Sandy the year
before right it was suddenly I was even
though we were in different grades and
we had just converged in school like we
were still like running with different
groups and but we were so ultimately it
always came back to 100 but so like you
do more Mitzvah I found the tape oh yeah
oh I so it's like tons of photos yeah it
was such an iconic day for me
everybody was Dirty Dancing Yeah it was
like it's Benji yeah oh my God Benji
yeah Benji big shout out to you brother
for like Chris Farley before there was
one yeah absolutely absolutely and the
nicensing twins I love those two yeah I
played for that we were on a baseball
team together uh you and I you got
remember Eric just moved back to
Jersey's dad was the manager of her team
I was really good at baseball when I was
little and got Dr I was in a 10 year old
league and the way North Edison did it
is I got drafted to like the majors yes
and because you were better than the
other yeah I was yeah it was really we
had a really great team that year and uh
and that actually ended my career they
moved me up too fast but I remember I
was with all those older kids
um and I just remembered him nice and
since Dad was like the [ __ ] bad oh
yeah oh yeah Artie I love that yeah
yeah and John Longo's Dad yes you know
John Long John
yes Dad was the best was his dad is one
of the football coaches yeah yeah I was
gonna say yeah
very good yeah in high school too yeah I
remember when I met I actually met
somebody in Italy on a wine trip when I
was like 30 that graduated with that
whole crew they might have been in your
grade or my grade and they just knew
Vinnie and long ago and Michael bottles
of these guys that I was friends like
your bottles check this out I opened the
brewery in Charlotte
um recently yeah like it's my first job
when I went to Charlotte and you mean
three years ago no last year yeah so I
hadn't spoken about so it turns out
Michael bottles hits me up on Facebook
he's like hey my daughter goes to UNC
Charlotte I've been smoking I haven't
spoken to this guy in [ __ ] 30 years
you know what I mean like I have so many
great memories so it turns out I ended
up hiring his daughter to be like my
late houses he comes down I haven't seen
this guy in 30 years it's such a great
time he came to the brewery you want to
hear a fun fact that you definitely
don't know back to like we were running
in slightly different circles at this
point Michael bottles
what trick-or-treating in Dogwood
Meadows my last Halloween me Michael
bottles and Vinnie
trick-or-treated in Dogwood Meadows as
seventh graders and on remember when you
go in Dogwood Meadows and you make a
left to go to me right if you went
straight yeah Eric Conrad lived on that
street over Eric Conrad I'd love to find
you bro ever cotton Brad's parents were
divorced he lived in Florida or Texas
during the year but he'd come to visit
his dad remember Conrad is the first kid
I bought baseball cards with okay in
1984. WoW Eric do you remember Eric
Conrad or did you you called me the name
is definitely anyway on that street I'll
never forget it be Michael bottles and
Vinnie start trick-or-treating right
after walking from school from John
Adams we go down that street and some
lady put out a wheelbarrow and I mean a
[ __ ] this is the like not like a
Walmart wheel like a actual [ __ ]
wheelbarrow filled with like 80 000
pieces of candy wow that's me Michael
bottles and bitty took the [ __ ]
wheelbarrow and with all the candy and
I'm like well to get a Robbie's yard
because I was always Central he was
right there
oh my God it was also Central was Gary
who's right behind him so that was it
Michael you actually I don't need the
well we rolled it all three of us
enrolled the whole [ __ ] thing which
made no [ __ ] sense because we should
have just taken the candy out but we
thought what the [ __ ] that's right I was
just gonna jump in because of the
Halloween thing I mean I was I was
talking to my kids about this I just
looked at the years 1987 Halloween fell
on a Saturday
we went out trick-or-treating Yumi and
Marissa on Saturday morning we were
walking up to people in your cul-de-sac
we're just pulling in from the grocery
store like eight o'clock in the morning
we used to hit every house in the
condors I don't remember that was one
year but we had every every house in the
condos and we went to the other condos
that were right near there um The Oaks
and made the maple Town access to them
townhouses yeah we connected all of
those then we hit tingly Lane and
doubled back to my house we changed
costumes and we went out again yeah we
went out again Halloween was a [ __ ]
babies
for apples with all that makeup yeah I
was so like that talk about competitive
yeah I needed to get the apples because
they had a quarter in it yeah and I
would die for a corn bag just so it's
very clear to everybody Andy's not
joking I'm gonna die for 25 cents we
didn't do you remember the miniature
golf course in Robbie's backyards yes
and one other person stopped okay but
then we have to talk about Marissa yeah
who lived on we we would do lemonade on
Marissa's house and that's when that
shot and the democracial the mini flea
market yeah
that's that's what my early marketing
phase came and I'm like this is not a
garage by the way this is a garage sale
that had nine items
package and some of your stuff was like
oh my God it was promotional stuff for
the liquor store and that guy gave
remember when he got the 10 when he did
the 10 Bill and then he wanted to come
back but we were gone yeah but we didn't
do that on purpose no we we're just
tired we ran out of it and then we ran a
lemonade lemonade we were 10 cents I
always believed in low price so it was
in the quarters
and the guy came up with a ten dollar
bill that ten dollar bill was like a
trillion I actually thought it was a
million dollars
yeah I don't think he even like got it
out of his pocket before it was in my
pocket yes
he filled his like bike thing and like
that's why I in my trash talk videos do
it now because it's for that guy and
then we gotta find that guy what we did
if there's some random guy I remember
riding a bike in Edison New Jersey
20 kids and filled a water bottle for a
ten dollar bill we need to find him yeah
but then what we did after that was what
we did every single day if you remember
the last day of school every single year
we would all walk up to it used to be a
crowd since that was 7-Eleven yeah so
walk up there without whatever money we
had we used to buy like jugs of lemonade
and iced tea Gary's favorite candy
mambas at the time I love mamas we used
to go anytime whatever we got I mean
chips everything we just go back sit on
my back deck and just sit there and just
show prepare ourselves
and we used to talk about and plan our
summer oh my God we used to talk about
and try and plan out our summer as much
as we can like because I mean let's face
it Gary was always in charge
even if somebody else came to take
charge he took it back right away but
like I mean yeah that was it Robbie go
ahead obviously I remember something so
similar to that word I don't know if it
was the last day of school but it was we
we did some lemonade stand garage sales
something we made some money right we
might have made like 60 bucks I remember
Gary was like all right here's the deal
guys we have 60 30 of it goes away we
don't even think about that that's fine
get it out of your mind
go to trousers and we're gonna do it big
and we went you know [ __ ]
sitting out in your deck behind your
house and your mom comes out with the
bowls put some chips in there we got the
music going I remember when I was your
sister I remember at that moment yeah we
built this city I remember this we love
that bucket
yes we we or I just it's like I could I
just have a snapshot of that moment in
my mind Marissa who else who else we
need to give some shout outs just so
people can like like email us and like
like friends who listen to this that
know these people remember Robin who is
the dude that moved into lip near you
I think it was an Asian family yes yes
they remember Taiwan I'm trying I don't
remember it was Reuben and Robin it was
something like that right okay
I remember that his mom did the crushed
ice yes with the red beans it was like
the weighted like every time I still see
that in restaurants it immediately and
we used to play Monopoly with them yes
do you remember we did this [ __ ]
Monopoly with those dudes they live like
a few doors down for me yes I remember
that that's exactly right I remember
them I remember them who else do it
Jonathan casadoy yeah
of course Williams yeah of course
[ __ ] Brian passed away yes yeah those
guys were Thug that was like they were
so there was something like listen
Edison had like some interesting parts
of medicine
yeah that was a [ __ ] there was a lot
of there was a lot of you know what's so
funny here's a fun thing to talk about
that would be good for parents like
fighting was real yeah
[Music]
if I lost I wanted to fight I remember I
fought a kid his name was Rashawn the
car
I remember him he was I guess his
family's from India but nice kid I don't
know what happened we got like an
argument in gym class we're playing
dodgeball I got him out he said
and we ended up where I were fighting
and I remember it was it was Middle
School this is where the world was
better yeah the explosive flight was
over
you'd be good yeah you hung it out and I
and I just remember we met in Marcos
Hill yeah Marcus Marcos if you're
listening yeah you at the hill by John
Adams where the ice cream truck was the
ping pong table in the back that's right
yeah and the fight I mean that was the
signature moment of my middle school
career was my fight with Odette in that
where I was very close to losing right
somehow mustered up the energy to get
him off me and then kicked them in the
face and his whole face exploded
and then a guy stopped the car and
pulled us apart and he ran off
like that was like that was the
crossroads of my life
that fight Anthony was definitely there
yeah I was sixth grade yeah
Marissa was there and he was there I'm
not sure I don't think you were there I
was there for definitely one of the
earlier ones yeah you were there for one
of them for sure I remember there was at
least three fights there was three
fights that one in sixth grade was out
there that was the big one yeah because
ODed pushed me in the morning into a
locker and got on top of me and then I
thought it was a non-event and by lunch
I went to lunch and everybody at lunch
is like yeah and I was like this is
something I like it broke my framework
so I had to I went up to Odette in lunch
like we're fighting and Marcus's after
school and then the hype built oh yeah
that's what it was and [ __ ] there was
you know how it is there was probably
only 40 kids there but it felt like 40
000. yeah it felt like WrestleMania
three Pontiac Michigan it was everything
I remember it was I remember right
before like we're both in our like sides
and we're about to go in the middle I
literally vividly it's amazing this is
1986 this is [ __ ] 40 something years
ago I remember vividly saying to myself
if I lose this fight it's over over yeah
I think it's all over I can't go to
school anymore everything I've built
here in the last six years there's I
remember being petrified and he got off
it's kind of like the Jets Bills game
yesterday he was like 14-3 before we got
settled in right literally that's the
fight Odette was on top of me at that
point he was like solidly bigger than me
oh definitely he was on top of me I
remember that yeah you were like this I
was on the ground and like trying to
like Dodge the punches and just remember
thinking like this is almost over now
and like I knew I was so crazy mentally
that even if he landed clean that I like
I knew that he had a like seriously
actually make me go unconscious for me
to stop right oh absolutely I knew that
about myself then and now I didn't I
just didn't I just knew that if he got a
clean shot and and it just like if
somebody ended it like it would have
been a loss like a decision right so I
remember vividly deciding the only thank
God we all wrestled so much I was able
to like do the [ __ ] side to side side
and when we fell off I had the leverage
and I [ __ ] kicked him right in his
[ __ ] face and he just started
bleeding so heavy and Tyler's bunting
was his boy main recipes and I'm
watching them run back towards the
school that's probably like you're crazy
his face like explode
I feel like
one of the guys was told I wasn't there
oh well understood I mean
37 times for the next 24 hours yeah like
I was yeah your crown make a documentary
about it like you know like that was big
the one fight I had with that kid
Rashawn was yeah you were there you were
like my height man you were like 100 I
remember it I don't remember him
I remember how much I needed you to win
yes we were we were both pretty young
you know I was about the same height
very same uh but I was a wrestler too
and you know we were very physical kids
very very athletic and uh I just
remember he was a bigger kid and he was
pissed because he really I really got
under his skin at dodgeball whatever I
did and what I said yeah I might have
called his mother
was around Marcus's Hill and Gary's it
was just getting there early lay a
couple shots in next thing you know
somebody's gonna break it up you're
gonna be the winner
yeah don't wait don't let him strike
first that's right go fast go for the
kill you know so yeah so so you know the
first like 30 seconds of the fight which
kind of you know yeah each other
outsidering each other up and I'm like
I'm like Rocky's Corner yes Andy he's
gone I can't wait to do something so I
just remember at one point I just go for
it I just rush him I grab him I grab him
by the shirt he picks me up off the
ground lifts me up it's much bigger than
me then I grabbing a headlight we're on
the ground we're scrapping I might have
scraped his lip and Drew a little bit of
blood and I remember he gets up he
tastes the blood and Gary looked at me
he goes
so so I just said all right
I remember people getting into fights in
at Martin Luther King winning but
getting scratched and like remember like
even then I was thinking about like how
people thought things right I'm like
blood went that's right yeah no that's
right because to your point shortly
after that this kid takes a little blood
he looks over me he saw Rex because he
knew all right I'm losing his fight if I
don't do something big so he comes in
and I swear to God he hit me with three
body blowers that was solid didn't phase
me somehow I guess I just yeah too much
adrenaline but he got me good like he
had me by the shirt he was like hauling
into me three clean shots then I pushed
him away I threw a punch didn't land it
and then I just remember somebody
stepped in Mark was like all right it's
over it's over Andy's the winner he drew
blood and it was like the kid Vashon his
his mind was blown he's like I just hit
him with like three a makers and I'm
ultimate with the L because I got a
little scratch on my ass but that's just
how it was and then Gary immediately
[Music]
the big dude that was like one security
guard oh no no okay I don't remember all
right don't worry about it
how about the election what do you
remember about 10th grade election fifth
grade election we made posters 24 7.
yeah
my mom yeah you were double winner yeah
I was back in both of both my boys
quiz question do you know who I went
against for president I'm just gonna ask
you who did you oppose because I was it
was it a girl yeah
Turner who was
I remember it was someone who was fairly
popular yeah it was a battle I'll know I
want to hear it I can't think of it
though my sister is screaming right now
listening to the podcast because this
girl's sister was also in her class so
she was talking [ __ ] in second grade I'm
sure if you give me the name I'm gonna
know Kim
delay okay
no Ellen was friends with her sister yes
you know was friends with her right the
kid okay she had a younger one who's but
Kim was in my Ellen was in my grave
Helen and Kim were definitely Kim Delhi
was a good student so she was probably
in Ellen's back yeah because from sixth
grade on they had Junior High in high
school you guys and they're both they're
both brilliant yeah yeah that's who I
beat fifth grade that was a Captain
Morgan giveaway yeah
I only wore liquor promotions yeah my
entire childhood yeah I remember you
with the Johnny Walker show that at some
point for some reason 100 it was just so
wild like how much liquor stuff I wore
that's all I've worn spot McKenzie we
were in sixth grade this is literally
Bud Light yeah and like we're wearing
Bud Light t-shirts costumes
I had Budweiser posters I had Marlboro
posters
yeah absolutely that was a little later
something you had a pool table in your
basement yes it was all different Like
Liquor merch yeah my dad yeah
and dark yeah that's where I had my
Nintendo that's what we did yes yes
oh man we had some reasons we just would
yeah we used to do like for hours for
hours who was that kid that we went to
Hebrew school with that lived on the
corner of Oak Tree Road that wasn't
where krausers was he was across the
street
oh my God right Brian Alexa
what does that mean oh yeah is that the
name yeah didn't you go to jail is that
the same guy I'm not sure there used to
be a gas station across the trousers
that's not silver yeah Ryan Alex says
yes
I'm pretty sure he got he got busted for
a major drugs thing a bathroom or his
dad
his dad was a coach John riggy was
another
he was like 18 year older than me but
yeah
I was a wide receiver
in three seasons we won one game in
Taiwan and we lost like we were like oh
six and one every year is there a kid in
my class do you remember Michael Smith
like a big dude with glasses I never
sells it right Michael Smith right is
that his name was it was he really big
dude I think so like yeah like you like
you like a big dude Michael
he was more of a book type
see this is we there was actually a year
where all three of us were in the same
school
oh no you left yeah you [ __ ] left
beginning either the end of six the
beginning of seven I think it was the
beginning of seven I think he was
beginning to seven too right yeah
because we were trying to John Adams is
John Adams to sixth seventh and eighth
right yes there was there was one year
I'm telling you I know this in my brain
you were an eighth Eric me and Andy were
in seventh until he left Marissa and
Marissa yeah
Ella was so much smarter than us in
grades like I didn't even like consider
Eleanor green I was like she's going to
Princeton right which I mean yeah you
know like I just remember it translates
to this day I mean
she was so brilliant yeah yeah she's
just always studying though which I
didn't like yeah I mean she found time
for sports too she was yeah
she used to try to get those Nintendo
Power magazines just the final hidden
stuff and get the cheat codes and
everything else it was huge
contractions
[Music]
what about what about let's talk more
about Robbie's yard we did the jungle oh
tell him about the casino story okay the
green box the green box
that was on my yard it was out but it
was electricity box and we used to catch
worms snakes
snakes Turtles frogs Turtles worms there
was a lot of trees
nothing like that anymore
it was filled with like tadpoles five
years ago yeah we're the twins yeah
box
like it was our [ __ ] I remember it
was it'd be freezing cold we would sit
on it yeah stay warm that goes back to
like it's November and it's beautiful
outside like five by October it was
[ __ ] freezing we had 16 layers
playing football yeah the weather
with quicksand I was like yeah I thought
quicksand was the most
in the 80s everybody did he's like
trying to make it and we try to figure
out how to slip and slide yep slipping
sizes sliding down the hill that was the
best remember okay at Bishop bar they
had the used to go there once in a while
yeah when we couldn't we went down the
hill in the backyard a bar backyard my
car burying the radio from my bike in my
driveway the day before my driveway I
remember it's still there I remember
when we dug all these wrestling figures
when we got a little older in those
systems I know that was crazy I still
look for more of them whenever I'm
outside
childhood man it shapes you so much it
really does yeah absolutely I mean we're
literally literally 40 years later
sitting here like talking about this
stuff like it's yesterday it was 40
years ago this past summer you know what
I mean it really you know your parents
and like what you do when you're young
and the environment yeah like the jersey
of it all yeah just the arrow I have one
more fun thing about Gary and I so Gary
and I obviously devastated when you
moved yes that was crazy obviously we
stayed in touch but obviously it was
very hard it was far away like
the Jets lost or beat they lost the
first game of the year the next year the
Jets played the Buccaneers and the only
person I want to talk to was you it was
one of the first times I talked to you
since I've moved yeah and it was 1714 I
had to look it up it's
1999 1989 90 Seasons but Buccaneers game
vividly go ahead
um so stay in touch for a while but it
was it was hard but yeah I'm playing
sports the girls in this high school and
so we literally Gary and I lost touch
for
at least at least 10 12 years at least
so funny story about this
Facebook had just come out at this point
she has come out my mom calls me I'm
running the wine program at SoHo on
George in New Brunswick New Jersey and
my mom calls me and she's like I swear I
just saw Gary's face on a billboard on
the turnpike now this is when Gary's
running Wine Library for his father and
everything so at this point I started
like investigating or whatever so that
then now that it was Google right so
like literally that's how you reconnect
yeah TV and how weird is it that like at
this point I'm a level two sum you're
running a massive and we actually it was
a long time ago but we actually did that
wine show together I remember the
Italian wine remember I actually ended
up buying that Rubio and carrying it for
the world I love it that was running it
that's how you got because it's a very
similar story Billboards in New Jersey I
was driving to work I think it was I was
on a dirty Turnpike yeah and I see this
guy's face on a billboard final library
and uh you know there's only one Gary
vaynerchuk he hadn't yet yeah so I just
I saw I saw the website I got to work
that day email I go to the I go to the
website says email Gary click email it
was the best you know 30 seconds
my [ __ ] phone rings he's like get the
[ __ ] I was sorry
I was so he's like we got together
Robbie's yard pretty quickly yeah yeah
we had to get together and then I just
remember it was just like you know 20 I
mean I left so abruptly I mean I lived
for about 10 years yeah you know my my
dad and my stepmom you know bought the
condo and Dogwood Meadows 10 ounce
rather dog Meadows movie scent they
split up it was like a sudden thing we
had no warnings just one day we got up
we're like all right you're going to
move with your grandmother say goodbye
pack your [ __ ] and we were gone and I
never got to say goodbye to them guys
say goodbye
no cell phones no Facebook
yeah you were just like are you pay like
a long distance call yeah I think the
reason we spoke up
yeah now that you said that I remember
that very bit yeah yeah I think I
remember about your sister the most was
me coming home from camp at the fart
spray and just chasing
my biggest memory she was the best
but I mean I I just I just can you know
think there were so many things we did
like
was it you rock didn't we find like
pepper spray once I think maybe it
wasn't even no I don't think so I
remember walking home and you might have
been with me somebody found pepper spray
I was like oh okay yeah
somebody sprayed it into the wind back
on our faces
they got me back to Lindsay if we can
find Lindsay what about when Lindsay had
like this shed
yeah bleach blonde hair
no no you were like even the picture
it's blondish well that's just it's a
little picture fair enough but we this
is eight this is 1982 man first couple
yes but let me set it up yes we go into
the shed now Marissa and Lindsay were
better athletes than all of us we had
like real like athletic and like they
were all athletic and like we were like
literally doing up who can hit the wood
in the shed the hammer the hardest we're
seven years old
regular old six
Hammer like a real [ __ ] hammer and
we're like boom boom boom taking turns
yeah
now it's my turn and I'm hitting this
thing and they're like come on hoarder
they're talking [ __ ] like they always do
come on you can do it harder I take a
swing the claw part of the hammer right
to the back of the head think about it
Hammer double fisted hammer in front of
your face swing back hands he went into
his head the blood is gushing Lindsay's
mom was a nurse she took care of me
called my mom walked me home yeah
I'll never forget that yeah
though you're right the jungle gym yeah
it sucks
Robbie's yard in my yard yeah that was
it that was like the connection there
was our universe I still live there and
I still got my back window every day and
I see your old house I see your old girl
53 Teaberry Drive yeah now two houses on
arms all right I bring my kids trick or
treating there when I have them for
until this year that's awesome all right
boys it's a wrap I hope everybody
enjoyed these stories that's a fun
little thing but it's definitely meant
to inspire some reach out so on this
Thanksgiving while I know we have the
long weekend and a long week reach out
to an old friend find them use Google
like go use Facebook like do it it is so
worth it the joy of having these guys
the last two days is unparalleled you
can never you can't replace you can't no
matter how your life evolves your
childhood friends or your childhood
friends it's just super [ __ ] real
it's totally and uh and I love you guys
yeah
we wouldn't be the people we are today
if we didn't have those experiences
sorry love you guys love you guys love
you too cheers awesome